hi there steve kaufman you know some
while ago i did a video on classroom
learning and
independent learning
and i sort of made them almost it may
have appeared as if i was contrasting
the one with the other
and
certainly i have had some rather un
dynamic and
unsuccessful
language learning experience in
classrooms and i think many of us have
but one should always be careful because
i have met a teacher
a tremendously dynamic teacher who
teaches high school in the united states
in delaware
and uh he i had an interaction with his
class spanish class he's a teacher of
spanish
and i talked to some of his students who
have learned extremely well and who are
very enthusiastic because the is
enthusiastic
and in fact we have developed a program
with them around link which is becomes
in a one of the tools that he uses
uh he's very much
proponent of the crashing approach the
input based learning approach in fact he
organized a conference
at his school where he invited educators
in the area and he had stephen crash and
come
and and present to them
more than once and i also participated
in that discussion as well
and there are other equally enthusiastic
teachers at school on elsewhere
so
i just want to mention this it was
exciting for me to talk first of all to
uh the learners this teachers spanish
learners and then to talk to other
teachers down there and just to see that
sometimes although the you know the
weight the inertia of curricula of
you know everything that is sort of
part of that whole institutionalized
learning
system that we have some of that
can sometimes discourage initiatives but
here's a teacher and others like him who
are doing what they think is best for
their students and have infected their
students with this enthusiasm for
language learning and it was very very
encouraging to see so i'm not naming any
names because i don't have really his
permission to talk about him
but i just want to say that if you have
an enthusiastic teacher and who
understands the importance of of input
and enjoying the language and real
meaningful situations in the language
the classroom can be a wonderful place
to learn
so thank you for listening